vous allez bientôt parler avec vous je
t'appellerai dans les prochains jours
donc pour lui parler de la situation et
en particulier du guerrier sur le
nucléaire civil et des sujets
d'infrastructures civiles qui sont
aujourd'hui bombarder dans un contexte
très difficile pour beaucoup de
population là encore vu avec une
maternité qui a été qui a été parlé ces
dernières années la conférence au mois
de décembre alors la conférence au mois
de décembre c'est un rendez-vous très
important je décide qui est le fruit de
mes échanges avec le président zellinski
et je le dis parce que il regroupe
beaucoup de parties prenantes qu'on voit
aujourd'hui nos mères les pompiers qu'on
a vu nos forces de sécurité intérieure
l'objectif c'est on a parlé beaucoup de
soutien militaire de soutien financier
on a parlé parfois de reconstruction
mais ce dont a besoin l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est d'aide à la résilience
et la résistance civique c'est-à-dire à
un moment où on voit bien la saillant
russe était épuisé de désespérer le
peuple en bombardant les canalisations
les générateurs électriques en les
plongeant dans le froid l'obscurité
parfois les écoles et autres c'est de
tenir cet hiver
[Musique]